[Musique]
bref mes bébés par rapport aux lois des
influenceurs franchement c'est trop bien
ce qu'ils ont fait moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec eux et là il
y a mon avocat qui est en train de
préparer genre tout ce que je dois faire
parce qu'en fait moi avec mes réseaux
j'ai fait tellement de conneries j'ai
pas envie de me prendre une amende ou de
me faire suspendre donc je trouve ça
bien qu'ils aient fait des lois qu'ils
encadrent ce métier parce
qu'influenceurs c'est un nouveau métier
donc il y a pas de loi mais il va
falloir que je respecte toutes ces lois
et moi ça me fait trop peur mais je vais
faire attention
chers collègues comme Maeva gaynam qui
incarne pour beaucoup les dérives de
l'influence commerciale faites attention
à la loi qui arrive un grand nombre
d'influenceurs et au-delà nous
soutiennent mais ils attendent avec
impatience l'entrée en vigueur de ce
texte qui va venir mettre des règles là
où régner surtout pour l'instant la loi
de la jungle
mettre fin à la loi de la jungle ce sont
les mots d'Arthur de la porte députés et
socialistes pour décrire le monde des
influenceurs il serait 150000 en France
dans ce nouveau numéro des grands débats
on s'intéresse aujourd'hui à ce secteur
qui s'est largement développé ces
dernières années avec son lot de dérive
et d'arnaque pour y remédier une
proposition loi transpartisane a été
adoptée cette année à l’assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi portée
par le socialiste Arthur de Laporte et
par son collègue apparenté Renaissance
Stéphane vogeta l'objectif est bien
c'est de reconnaître l'influence
commerciale comme une activité à part
entière mais aussi de lutter contre les
dérives de certains influenceurs le
texte a été examiné le jeudi 30 mars par
les députés et cette Arthur de la porte
qui a ouvert les débats
ce qui nous anime c'est tout d'abord la
protection des victimes de l'influence
elles sont tellement nombreuses
dropshipping produit défectueux ou
dangereux promotion illégales de la
colle détournement de matériel médical
pour faire maigrir par exemple conseil
bidon de santé rémunérés promotion de
placement financier dangereux de la
pratique illégale de la chirurgie
esthétique absence de transparence sur
le caractère promotionnel et
publicitaire des publications une
minorité d'influenceurs peut scrupuleux
à tout oser jusqu'à s'enrichir
frauduleusement en abusant de la
confiance ou de la crédulité de leur
communauté le chapitre 2 de cette loi
vise à mettre fin à ses différentes
dérives
prenons l'exemple de cette femme je me
sens tellement bête j'ai convaincu mon
mérite mon mari d'investir nos économies
entre le trading anime les monnaies on
en est à une perte d'environ 10.000
euros tout ce qu'on avait réussi à
économiser pour notre famille
aujourd'hui avec cette loi la honte doit
changer de camp
parce que nous croyons fermement que
c'est au Parlement que ce fabric la loi
une idée qui pourrait paraître saugrenue
dans un contexte politique où le
Parlement a été maltraité où l'on a trop
souvent l'impression que le gouvernement
préfère faire seul la loi contre les
représentants du peuple nous avons à
contrario fais le choix de constituer
autour de ce texte avec mon corps
rapporteur Stéphane Végéta ce qu'il
appelle avec malice une bulle de paix
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir mais
cette loi s'articule autour de quatre
points cardinaux clarifier encadré
responsabiliser éduquer notre boussole
est simple la protection des
consommateurs et de la santé publique
nous ne voulons plus recevoir ces
témoignages j'avais commandé une machine
à enlever les points noirs pour ma fille
avec snap je n'ai jamais eu le
remboursement j'ai aussi acheté pin-up
secret pour l'acné de ma fille une
catastrophe ça sèche et ça empire
ce capitalisme charismatique sous
couvert de morale sanitaire pour
reprendre l'expression du chercheur
Joseph Godefroy a des effets sur les
corps et sur les vies
nous définissons d'ailleurs dans
l'article premier ce qui est l'influence
commerciale et nous espérons réussir
ainsi à mieux l'encadrer je voudrais
finir mon propos en rappelant que nous
faisons ici le droit et non la morale et
je souhaiterais dire que les réseaux
sociaux sont une opportunité formidable
pour l'expression des talents nous
devons accompagner ces nouveaux modes de
création et de consommation mais les
encadrer aussi
j'inspire les gens les petits les grands
je suis belle je fais du make-up je veux
la Fame sans les responsabilités la
flemme donc fait de la quantité ça me
peine quand dans les médias on parle de
moi pour dire combien je gagne tous les
mois rappeler Squeezie dans son titre
influenceur chers collègues il ne tient
qu'à vous qu'à nous de faire que les
influenceurs désormais responsabilisés
ne soient plus l'objet de l'eau propre
public mais que l'inventivité de nos
créateurs de contenu deviennent la
source d'une fierté collective nous
sommes donc ici aujourd'hui pour
encadrer cette activité d'influence
commerciale mais aussi pour mettre fin à
ses dérives pour dire aux victimes de
ces dérives nous vous avons entendu
était nécessaire afin d'éviter notamment
les textes contradictoires et les
batailles partisanes ce texte infinie
n'obéit à une boussole protéger les
consommateurs une boussole avec ces
quatre points cardinaux clarifier
encadré responsabiliser et éduqué la
clarification des règles Arthur de la
porte vient de l'évoquer l'encadrement
c'est rendre obligatoire l'établissement
d'un contrat écrit entre l'influenceur
et son agence ou son annonceur c'est
aussi rendre l'application de la loi
française incontournable et s'assurer
que la responsabilité civile des acteurs
soit engagés et ce même s'ils exercent
leur activité depuis l'étranger la
responsabilisation c'est reprendre le
règlement européen sur les services
numériques le DSA et l'appliquer à
l'influence commerciale pour ainsi
imposer aux plateformes une série
d'obligations pour qu'il soit mise à
disposition du public des outils de
signalement efficaces et pour que les
plateformes répondent au signalement et
collaborent avec nos autorités
et enfin car il faut toujours penser
d'abord à notre jeunesse l'éducation
c'est intégré la notion de
sensibilisation contre les dangers
d'ordre commercial au sein de la
formation au risque numérique dispensés
dans nos établissements scolaires tout
cela aboutit sur un texte qui propose
d’établir pour la première fois en
Europe un encadrement transversal de
l'acte d'affluence commerciale un texte
qui pourra sans doute inspirer d'autres
pays voire même l'Europe
un esprit de co-construction pour faire
de la France vous l'avez compris l'un
des premiers pays au monde à définir
juridiquement ce qu'est un influenceur
côté gouvernement la ministre Olivia
Grégoire salue elle aussi ce travail
transpartisan
mesdames messieurs les députés si
quelqu'un m'avait dit il y a 10 ans
que j'aurai un jour un matin l'honneur
de monter à cette tribune en tant que
ministre
pour prononcer les noms de Nabilla
Benattia je ne vous aurais pas cru
je ne sais pas au juste ce que je
n'aurais pas cru
le fait d'être ministre
ou le fait d'être ici devant la
représentation nationale à parler de
Nabilla
mais le monde est ainsi en disant
la politique s'est ouverte à de
nouvelles personnalités en disant
la société s'est ouverte à de nouveaux
horizons il y a 10 ans donc presque jour
pour jour
la France entière faisait la
connaissance de Nabilla qui s'inquiétait
de ne pas avoir de shampoing
à l'époque on se moquait aujourd'hui on
l'apprend très au sérieux comme de
nombreuses autres influenceurs par tous
les experts de l'opinion publique qui
savent que leur prise de parole peut
avoir des effets massifs décisif sur la
décision d'achat de pas moins de 42
millions de nos compatriotes
la vie évolue parfois plus rapidement
que la vie politique vient de dire
justement le Président kasbarium il
n'est donc pas nouveau que des
célébrités se fassent les ambassadeurs
d'une marque ou d'une entreprise ce
qu'il y a de nouveau c'est la manière
dont la publicité s'invite chez les gens
les réseaux sociaux ont créé un canal de
publicité
aussi révolutionnaire en réalité que le
jour où la télévision s'est installée
dans nos foyers avec une instantanéité
dans tous les publicitaires ont bien
compris l'enjeu 42 millions de
Françaises et de Français achètent et
ont acheté l'an passé sur Internet plus
de 22 millions le font par
l'intermédiaire de notre téléphone je
pense ne pas trop m'avancer si jamais
l’hypothèse qu'il s'est même déjà trouvé
ici une ou deux députés qui aurait fait
ses courses ici même depuis l'hémicycle
comme je ne veux froisser personne nous
dirons qu'une telle scène a forcément dû
avoir lieu pendant la précédente
législature pendant une suspension de
séance certainement sur une plateforme
française je n'en doute pas et pour un
objet absolument indispensable c'est
évident rien d'interdit de faire de la
publicité
que ce soit par une bonne vieille
affiche ou sur un réseau social
madame Benattia Vergara en est devenu un
exemple assez dépend et je promets ici
d'arrêter les mentions de son cas mais
c'est au terme d'une enquête d'ailleurs
de la DGCCRF en juillet 2021 qu'elle a
été condamné à une amende pour pratique
commerciale trompeuse internet n'est pas
une zone de non-droit et où que vous
alliez la DGCCRF sera vous rappeler à
l'ordre pourtant je vous l'accorde ce
cadre juridique n'est pas suffisamment
connu par les influenceurs eux-mêmes et
à plus forte raison par les
consommateurs dans le même temps le
caractère diffuse des réseaux sociaux
facilite les pratiques illégales c'est
un constat d'autant plus regrettable
comme l'ont dit les rapporteurs
d'ailleurs quand on sait que près de la
moitié des personnes suivant les
influenceurs ont entre 15 et 24 ans une
population pour qu'il l'achat en ligne
est aussi naturelle que de pousser un
caddie peut être même encore plus
naturel que de pousser un caddie
nous avons donc d'un côté des dizaines
de milliers d'influenceurs qui ne
connaissent pas tous leurs devoirs nous
avons de l'eau des dizaines de millions
d'influencés qui ne connaissent pas tous
leurs droits je note tout d'abord
que le gouvernement les députés les
Français se rejoignent sur la nécessité
de définir l'influence commerciale ce
qui fait d'ailleurs l'objet de notre
premier article cette définition elle a
été minutieusement travaillée construite
j'en salue la portée c'est à partir de
cette définition que nous pourrons plus
efficacement promouvoir les outils déjà
ou bientôt à notre disposition des
outils légaux comme les contrats écrits
entre les annonceurs et les influenceurs
entre les agences et les influenceurs
dont le gouvernement demandera avec vous
la systématisation mais aussi des outils
d'accompagnement comme le guide de bonne
conduite des influenceurs qui a été
présenté la semaine dernière par Bruno
Le Maire et qui est d'ailleurs
disponible en ligne
je sais que les parlementaires sont
pleinement sensibilisés à ces problèmes
c'est bien tout l'intérêt d'un texte
construit par les députés en lien étroit
avec les acteurs les Français les
administrations un texte ou personne
n'agit pour le coup en influenceurs
puisque précisément nous ne faisons la
promotion que d'une seule cause
l'intérêt général nous ne bénéficions
d'aucune contrepartie seulement celle de
savoir qu'ensemble nous parviendrons à
ce que nous concitoyens soient mieux
protégés je rappelle pour terminer que
grâce à vous et avec vous en plus des
travaux menés sous l'égide de Bruno Le
Maire à Bercy ces derniers et moi et
semaines la France sera possiblement ce
soir grâce à l'initiative parlementaire
la première nation européenne à disposer
d'un véritable cadre complet
d'accompagnement et de protection de
l'influence commerciale en cela et pour
cela je commence la journée par vous
remercier pour cette initiative et ses
travaux qui me semblent absolument
indispensables je vous remercie
convergence des points de vue dans
l'hémicycle un consensus qui ne se
démentira pas pendant la discussion
générale du texte même si certains
groupes politiques émettent quand même
quelques critiques écoutez
nous pouvons convenir que le sujet de la
réglementation du marché de l'influence
n'est pas à prendre à la légère en effet
les premières cibles de ces influenceurs
star des réseaux sociaux parfois suivis
par plusieurs millions d'anonymes sont
nos enfants nous adolescents et de
jeunes adultes qui ont parfois été
exposés quotidiennement pendant
plusieurs années aux poisons de la
téléréalité ce lien télévisuel poursuivi
numériquement sur les réseaux sociaux
créer une chimère d'intimité une
impression de confiance entre
l'influenceur et son public il n'en faut
pas moins à des individus
malintentionnés pour abuser de cette
confiance factice bâtie sur des
illusions des paillettes et beaucoup de
buzz
et certains s'en donnent à cœur joie en
effet la direction générale de la
concurrence de la consommation et de la
répression des fraudes relève lors d'une
enquête réalisée depuis 2021 que 6
influenceurs sur 10 en freinent la loi
c'est autant de potentiels victimes au
mieux trompé au pire escroquer et
infinés abusé
de haut niveau d'infraction ce haut
niveau d'infraction est symptomatique de
l'informalité de cette activité des
conditions de sa professionnalisation
que ce soit suite à une participation à
une émission de télévision au partage
régulier de son quotidien à des messages
humoristiques à des productions
artistiques ou vidéos ludiques on ne
choisit pas d'être influenceur on le
devient progressivement par la force des
choses il n'y a pas de formation
sérieuse qui ne soit pas elle-même
trompeuse qui puisse garantir de
transformer le parfait Kidam en
influenceurs l'absurdité de cette
profession et qu'elle est réservée à des
amateurs en outre affirmons-le cette
activité n'a rien de révolutionnaire les
influenceurs ne sont rien d'autre que
des publicitaires et à ce titre ils sont
soumis au même texte de loi que
n'importe quelle agence se publicitaire
c'est évident mais cela va mieux en le
disant
s'il a déjà cesserf relève des
infractions c'est bien qu'un cadre
existe
on est donc très loin du nomades décrit
parfois dans les médias et même par
certains parlementaires dès lors notre
travail doit être de trouver des
solutions pour former les influenceurs
aux droits qui s'appliquent à leur
activité
réciproquement on ne peut que déplorer
que les cibles de ces influenceurs ne
soient pas suffisamment armés pour faire
face à ces dangers
la situation d'autant plus préoccupante
que d'après l'agence event 87% des
enfants français possèdent un compte où
il publie régulièrement
lors de la première discussion en
commission de la proposition loi de
Messieurs les corps-à-porteurs nous
avions déjà proposé un amendement jugé
irrecevable pourtant curieusement
similaire à l'article 5 de cette
proposition de loi qui proposait lui
aussi d'instaurer des cours de
prévention dans les établissements
scolaires à cet égard bien que nous
n'ayons pas été officiellement invité
aux discussions transpartizanes sur ce
texte nous souhaitons tout de même vous
remercier messieurs les cours à porteurs
pour cette maintenus sous le manteau
ceci étant dit vos propositions restent
lacunaire lorsqu'elles ne se borne pas à
rappeler ce qui existe déjà on peine par
exemple à comprendre comment votre loi
permettra de forcer les influenceurs
installés à l'étranger à se faire
représenter légalement puisque leur
représentation légale constitue la
condition sinequanone pour le reposer le
droit français par ailleurs tant que le
gouvernement privilégiera les effets
d'annonce sans engager les moyens
financiers nécessaires on aura beau jeu
de légiférer prenez la direction
générale de la concurrence de la
consommation de la répression des
fraudes depuis 2007 ces effectifs ont
diminué Dakar soit 911 équivalentes en
plein en moins alors que l'émission la
DGCCRF sont de plus en plus larges avec
le développement du commerce en ligne
pour autant de notre côté nous
n'entendons pas créer d'occasion manquée
nous sommes ici pour faire oeuvres utile
pour les Français ainsi nous considérons
cette proposition de loi qui est ni plus
ni moins qu'une tentative non pas vaine
mais inaboutie que nous tâcherons
d'améliorer dans l'intérêt général et le
bien commun je vous remercie la
proposition de loi dont du débattons ce
matin se veut un texte pionnier en
Europe dans la régulation du secteur de
l'influence commerciale
elle porte une ambition partagée unanime
sur ses bancs celle de renforcer
l'encadrement de l'activité des
influenceurs afin de mettre fin aux
nombreuses dérives et pratiques
douteuses dont l'actualité nous offre
régulièrement des exemples
arnaque le placement financier sur
laquelle l'Autorité des marchés
financiers a déjà publié plusieurs mises
en garde arnaque au compte personnel de
formation aux abonnements cachés
promotion de médicaments et pratique
médicale dangereuse de produits
contrefaits de jeux d'argent de hasard
de boissons et compléments alimentaires
douteux la direction générale de la
concurrence de la consommation et de la
répression des fraudes mènent des
enquêtes depuis plusieurs années ces
enquêtes relèvent que les pratiques de
60% des influenceurs contrôlées
n'étaient pas conformes à la
réglementation et qu'au de la même
détromperies et arnaque avéré la
totalité des influenceurs contrôlées ne
respectez pas la réglementation relative
à la transparence du caractère
commercial de leur publication il était
essentiel de réagir et de légiférer sur
cette question
nous tenons donc à remercier les
rapporteurs pour le travail législatif
qu'ils ont conduit lequel définit un
cadre juridique clair en terme de
contractualisation d'obligations de
protection des consommateurs et de
protection des mineurs nous regrettons
toutefois que l'examen de ce texte en
commission et conduit un certain nombre
de recul comme à son habitude en effet
la majorité a tenu à laisser son
empreinte en transformant en droit mou
un cadre à l'origine plus contraignant
l'interdiction de la promotion de
médicaments des produits pharmaceutiques
et dispositifs médicaux prévus dans le
texte initial il passe à la trappe
l'interdiction de faire de la publicité
contre rémunération pour les jeux
d'argent et de hasard a été remplacé par
l'obligation d'informer par un bandeau
visible que ceux-ci sont réservés aux
personnes majeures
idem pour la promotion de boissons avec
ajout de sucre de sel ou d'édulcorants
ou la publicité relative aux formations
professionnelles
ce travail effectuant en commission
ainsi consisté à proposer un décalque du
cadre juridique relatif à l'encadrement
de la promotion de biens et de services
dans les autres médias cette analogie
n'est pas satisfaisante elle ne permet
pas en effet de prendre en compte la
spécificité du marketing d'influence et
ça parenté avec les phénomènes d'emprise
psychologique dans l'exposé des motifs
de la proposition de loi initiale vous
notiez à juste titre que la relation
faussement intimiste développée par les
influenceurs rassure ceux qui les
suivent grâce au ressenti parfois
trompeur de la transparence d'honnêteté
de proximité de bienveillance à leur
égard et les places ainsi dans la
situation de voir leur décision d'achat
déterminée par les indications des
influenceurs
u égard à cette particularité nous
aurions souhaité des mesures de
régulation plus fortes nous restons par
ailleurs assez circonspects sur le rôle
des signes alors de confiance
directement inspirés du règlement
européen sur les services numériques
si elle est le corollaire de l'absence
d'obligation générale de surveillance ou
de recherche active des faits par les
plateformes elle conduit peu ou proue à
une forme de sous-traitance aux
associations des missions de la DGCCRF
s'il est légitimes de reconnaître la
faculté aux associations de signaler
directement les contenus illicites aux
autorités elles n'ont pas l'occasion à
disposer elles n'ont pas pardon vocation
à disposer de pouvoir d'injonctions or
c'est ce que semble implicitement
reconnaître l'article 4 pour notre part
nous considérons que l'État ne serait en
l'espèce se défausser de ses
responsabilités la DGCCRF accuse
aujourd'hui un manque criant de moyens
pour procéder au contrôle et aux
enquêtes nécessaires pour réprimer
certaines pratiques illégales notamment
en marinière de marketing d'influence
l'annonce par le ministre de l'économie
de la création d'une brigade spécialisée
de 15 agents face à 150 000 influenceurs
mais en relief cette grave anomalie
si cette proposition de loi emporte donc
notre adhésion sur le principe nous
serons très attentifs au concours de nos
discussions et à la rédaction finale
avant d'exprimer un vote je vous
remercie
les députés commencent ensuite l'examen
de l'article 1 c'est la pierre angulaire
de cette proposition loi la définition
juridique de l'influenceur commercial
vaste débat chaque mot est discuté un
exemple avec Eric Bothorel
merci Madame frisante madame ministre
monsieur le rapporteur alors cet
abonnement propose une définition
alternative de l'activité d'influence
commerciale par voie électronique cette
dernière inclut la notion d'engagement
réciproque entre Marc et organisation un
influenceur pour caractériser la
relation commerciale entre les deux
parties à un lieu également les notions
de création et de diffusion qui sont des
caractéristiques centrales de l'activité
d'influence commerciale par voie
électronique et son juridiquement plus
précises que la promotion j'ajoute que
dans le Guide de votre pratique publiée
par Bercy lundi ce guide de votre
pratique indique que la mention
communication commerciale peut être
indiquée sur un contenu sponsorisé je
vous propose un président de considérer
que j'ai aussi défendu de 72 que 72 est
un amendement de repli sur la notion de
d'engagement réciproque on a eu ces
débats en commission sur la difficulté
de cerner finalement et de définir
l'activité d'un influenceur j'avais pris
comme exemple notre propre activité de
député dans la rédaction telle qu'elle
était proposée en commission
moi député je vais dans une entreprise
on m'invite à prendre un repas après
avoir visité l'entreprise et je fais le
la promotion produit alors si je prends
la définition telle qu'elle a été faite
je tombe sous le coup de l'obligation de
faire figurer un bandeau je me déplace à
l'étranger si le voyage est payé par une
puissance étrangère avec laquelle on a
des relations par ailleurs tout à fait
normalisées et que je défends une cause
et bien je peux être considéré comme
entrant dans le champ de de cette
définition c'est pour ça rapporteur que
m'arrêtant pas simplement un constat
j'ai tenté par ces rédactions d'apporter
ma contribution à une perfectibilité de
la rédaction du de la définition
d'influenceur je vous remercie sur les
deux points que vous soulevez je crois
que nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
discuter déjà en commission mais je
préfère le redire ici ça sera un avis
défavorable pour deux raisons parce que
la définition sur laquelle nous sommes
en train d'aboutir et finalement une
définition de consensus sur laquelle
nous avons énormément travaillé avec
l'ensemble des collègues de tous les
bancs et donc c'est pour cela que votre
amendement de réécriture complète le 67
ne paraît pas opportun puisqu'il est
aussi le fruit de ces discussions de cet
équilibre des travaux que nous avons pu
mener aussi en concertation avec le
gouvernement que je remercie donc voilà
premier point de forme mais sur le fond
sur le fond ce que vous soulevez votre
amendement il propose de dire de
mentionner la création de la création et
la diffusion de contenu comme des
conditions cumulatives qui font peser
finalement un risque juridique dans la
mesure où elle pourrait permettre à des
créateurs de contenu d’exiper non
soumission au régime par exemple s'ils
font diffuser un contenu par une
personne tierce voilà et donc là ça ça
engendrerait un risque de faire sortir
un nombre important de personnes donc
c'est pour cela que nous faisons d'abord
une demande de retrait pour éviter cet
effet de bord non désiré non souhaité ou
sinon ça sera un avis défavorable sur
l'abondance 72 que vous avez évoqué et
qui intègre dans le cadre d'un
engagement réciproque c'est un sujet
fondamental nous pensons déjà qu'il est
satisfait parce que nous avons indiqué
que la promotion se fait en contrepartie
bénéfice économique ou d'un avantage en
nature cette idée de contrepartie
souligne qu'il y a une forme
d'engagement de du diffuseur vers
l'auteur de enfin celui qui a la marque
ou l'agence mais le fait d'inscrire dans
la loi un engagement réciproque pourrait
faire peser un risque juridique
finalement parce que ça serait trop
restrictif on voudrait dire qu'il y a
forcément un contrat or nous allons
évoquer dans la suite du texte
l'idée que on peut avoir des seuils en
dessous desquels notamment pour les
avantages en nature il n'y a pas de
contractualisation et donc il faudrait
aller montrer faire la preuve qu'il n'y
a pas d'engagement réciproque s'il n'y a
pas de contrat sur ce sujet on a eu
beaucoup de discussions en amont de la
préparation de cette proposition de loi
et y compris avec notre collègue
beautorel sur le sujet de la
contrepartie et de l'avantage en nature
et moi ce que je tiens à préciser c'est
que si j'avais la même préoccupation que
Monsieur Bothorel j'ai été rassuré les
échanges avec nos deux rapporteurs et le
travail de fond parce que dans cette
article il est bien écrit en
contrepartie d'un bénéfice économique et
quand on regarde la définition de
contrepartie c'est une expression qui
signifie qu'il y a un échange volontaire
une compensation opérée à la suite d'un
accord passé entre deux parties qui se
sont entendus ce qui veut dire que par
exemple une jeune société française une
start-up qui fait des cosmétiques bio
dont tous les ingrédients sont faits en
France qui envoient des échantillons ou
des tubes de crème par exemple crème de
jour à l'ensemble des influenceurs et
influenceuses qui s'intéressent au
cosmétiques qui l'envoie aussi au
journaliste de elle du Figaro Madame de
toute la presse classique pour
découverte des produits sans demander
quoi que ce soit en contrepartie sans
donner d'injonction sur la façon dont
toi dont on doit parler de ces produits
sont bien finalement exclus de d'un
certain nombre d'obligations qui seront
dans cette loi l'objectif n'est pas
d'empêcher des personnes qui utilisent
l'envoi d'échantillons dans une mesure
raisonnable et de pouvoir continuer
d'avoir de la création de l'innovation
en particulier pour nos entreprises
françaises et de pouvoir communiquer
avec ces influenceurs qui sont qui
élargissent une communauté de
d'influenceurs dans le domaine de la
presse par exemple je vous remercie je
persiste les biens que l'on peut
recevoir dans le cadre d'échanges ou
d'activités avec des entreprises sont
strictement encadrées par le déontologue
et nous connaissons tous ici les règles
il n'empêche que les contreparties qui
peuvent arriver sous forme matérielle
constitue en elle comment dire une
contrepartie un bénéfice économique
est-ce que ça a une valeur alors en tout
cas moi j'ai une lecture qui est
peut-être plus comment dire
plus tordu
plus borderline pardon à la présidente
du mot reprend plus en frontières
la façon dont vous voyez les choses je
pense qu'il existe ce risque la volonté
c'était pas bien évidemment au travers
de cette série d'amendements c'est pas
de considérer que au contraire le
travail que vous avez accompli
transpartisan il est de qualité tout le
monde le souligne j'essaye simplement
d'être un peu le poil à gratter de celui
qui va le dire autrement pour qu'il
voudrait défendre des intérêts
différents je pense qu'il existe encore
aujourd'hui des fragilités juridiques
voilà pourquoi je maintiens un certain
moment
la définition alternative proposée par
Eric Bothorel ne sera pas adopté le
texte a aussi pour objectif d'encadrer
les relations entre les différents
acteurs avec la création d'un contrat
écrit entre l'influenceur et son
annonceur entre le créateur de contenu
et son agent mais le contrat écrit
doit-il être systématique c'est le débat
posé par Violette spielbot
oui madame la Présidente cette
proposition d'amendement intervient
suite au débat sur l'exonération pour
les avantages en nature ou les contrats
qui recouvriraient de très très faibles
montants l'objectif ici c'est de pouvoir
exonérer d'obligation de contractualiser
des marques ou avec des agents ou des
influenceurs dont la mesure où l'échange
économique serait très très faible cela
est pour protéger notamment des petites
startups des créateurs français qui
utilisent l'envoi d'échantillons de
produits de façon raisonnable et
raisonnée sur une année et donc je
propose en cet amendement un seuil pour
permettre d'exonérer ses acteurs de
l'obligation de contractualiser et je
crois qu'il y a une proposition de
réécriture dans un autre amendement des
rapporteurs qui permettra de prendre en
compte cette préoccupation je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission
oui alors sur le sur le fond
effectivement enfin nous sommes d'accord
madame suivboot avec votre vision des
choses sur le fait que il y a deux
choses il y a l'influenceur commercial
qui est défini par l'article premier et
à qui s'applique toute une série
d'interdiction de clarification et en
particulier les obligations de
transparence quant au caractère
promotionnel de ces de ces contenus
ensuite la question qui se posait et la
contractualisation l'obligation de
contrat écrit doit-elle s'imposer de la
même manière à tous les influenceurs
commerciaux sans question de seuil et
bien en fait nous avons déterminé en
consultant notamment avec vous
l'industrie que il était adéquat
d'établir un seuil minimum en dessous
duquel effectivement cette obligation
spécifique de contrat écrit de
s'imposait pas afin de ne pas
complexifier autre mesure l'opérabilité
de du business model de ces de ces
personnes donc c'est un avis favorable
ce sera aussi un avis favorable sur cet
amendement porté par Madame spielbot
merci je vais le mettre au bois avec un
avis favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement je rappelle qui est
inscrite un public sur cet amendement le
scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est clos
votant 43 exprimés 42 majorités 22 pour
42 contre 0
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
dans le viseur des députés également les
influenceurs qui opèrent depuis
l'étranger et bien la loi française
s'appliquera aussi à ses créateurs de
contenu au cours du débat le groupe
démocrate propose aussi de mettre en
place une responsabilité solidaire entre
l'annonceur et l'influenceur objectif
indemnisé les éventuels victimes des
influenceurs regardez
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues par cet amendement les députés
du groupe démocrate vous proposent
d'établir le principe d'une
responsabilité solidaire entre
l'annonceur et la personne qui exerce
l'activité d'influenceurs commerciales
et cela vis-à-vis des tiers qui sont
lésés dans le cadre d'une opération
d'influence commerciale cela permet
ainsi de responsabiliser à la fois la
personne qui exerce l'activité
d'influence donc l'influenceur mais
aussi l'annonceur mais surtout d'assurer
une meilleure protection du tiers lésé
qui pourra demander réparation d'un
préjudice ou bien à l'influenceur ou
bien à l'annonceur et cela le protège
ainsi d'un risque d'insolvabilité de
l'an ou l'autre correspondable
concrètement imaginons si un influenceur
vous vend une pilule miracle sensée
guérir le cancer vous l'aurez bien
compris ça n'existe pas et donc vous
êtes lésé dans cette affaire et bien en
instaurant cette solidarité responsable
vous pourrez demander réparation du
préjudice ou bien à l'influenceur ou
bien à son annonceur et bien entendu je
précise que ce sera l'autorité
judiciaire qui aura la liberté pour
fixer la juste répartition à la
contribution de la dette solidaire entre
l'annonceur et l'influenceur je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
monsieur le rapporteur alors la question
de l'indemnisation des victimes
d'éventuelles abus réalisées par des
influenceurs commerciaux en lien avec
l'exécution des contrats concernés est
effectivement essentielle nous sommes
donc favorables à l'insertion dramatique
de ce principe de co-responsabilité
merci Madame la la ministre
madame la députée Morel
ce sera aussi favorable
je vais le mettre au voile amendement
153 avec un avis favorable de la
commission et de madame la ministre qui
est pour
tes contre il est adopté
au cœur des discussions également
l'interdiction de certaines publicités
la proposition de loi rappelle que les
influenceurs doivent respecter le cadre
légal sur la promotion des biens et des
services unanimement les députés ont
aussi voté l'interdiction de la
publicité pour la chirurgie esthétique
ou pour les jeux d'argent et de hasard
auprès des mineurs la promotion de
l'alcool par les influenceurs s'invite
elle aussi dans les débats la parole est
à Karine le bon
si l'article 2 apprécie ce que les
influenceurs sont soumis aux
restrictions du code de la du code de la
santé publique notamment en termes de
publicité de produits alcoolisés il n'en
fait pas pour autant une interdiction
d'après le droit existant la pub
d'alcool est en effet autorisée sur
Internet sauf si le programme est
principalement destiné à la jeunesse
comme pour la presse écrite il serait
facile pour n'importe quelle influenceur
darguer le fait que son contenu est de
toute façon destiné un public majeur et
que la proportion de mineurs parmi ses
abonnés est très réduite alors même que
ça n'est pas réellement vérifiable c'est
la raison pour laquelle afin de ne
laisser aucune porte entre bâiller et
d'éviter d'innombrables recours et
procédures judiciaires il nous faut le
préciser dès maintenant que la publicité
d'alcool ne leur est pas permise la loi
est vain introduit déjà une différence
de traitement entre les canaux de
diffusion la pub pour l'alcool est
interdite à la télé et au cinéma
et nous voulons dans par cet amendement
aligner cette interdiction aux
influenceurs les enjeux de santé
publique sont trop grands vous
connaissez tous les effets de l'alcool
sur l'organisme et sur la société
49.000 morts par an en cause dans de
nombreux cas de violence et j'insiste
quand même sur tous les ravages causés
par le syndrome d'alcoolisation fœtale
qui touche 15000 bébés en France chaque
année
et toutefois
comme nous avons conscience de
l'importance de notre patrimoine nous
proposons une dérogation pour les
influenceurs spécialisés qui travaillent
pour des marques disposant d'une AOC ou
du AOP ainsi que ceux qui publient de
l'information euneau touristique en
raison de la difficulté de leur secteur
et de notre volonté de préserver le
patrimoine et le savoir-faire notre
territoire nous partageons tous la
volonté de prévenir l'alcoolisme et de
protéger nos jeunes en voyant un message
fort alignons la loi Evain de ce média
sur la télé et le cinéma je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
l'amendement 182 madame bassire je vous
remercie même la Présidente je ne peux
que souscrire à l'amendement porté par
ma collègue Karine Lebon et je ne
reviendrai pas sur les chiffres
alarmants évoqués et notamment en
outre-mer sur les conséquences néfastes
de l'alcool sur les accidents et le
syndrome fœtal d'alcoolisation fœtale
évoquée également par la députée le bon
nous avons également travaillé notre
amendement avec addiction France juste
repréciser que nous avons initialement
initialement l'encadrement des
publicités en faveur de l'alcool visé à
protéger les jeunes générations de
consommation excessive et une action
menée par addiction France montre que
plusieurs de milliers de contenus
promouvant une marque d'alcool on peut
être observé en un an sur les réseaux
sociaux la majorité des contenus en
freinent et vous et vous l'avez dit
collègue Karine Lebon la loi Eva ils
sont notamment
issus d'influenceurs dont la notoriété
telle que des mineurs sont très
certainement confrontés à ces
publications je rappelle que 80 15% des
adolescents fréquentes les réseaux
sociaux cette disposition permettra
d'appliquer la piste d'action de la
Mission interministérielle de lutte
contre les drogues et les addictions qui
souhaitent la mise en place de nouvelles
dispositions législatives sur le
marketing d'influence en faveur des
produits qui génèrent des addictions et
je vous remercie le sujet de la place de
l'alcool dans les promotions des
influenceurs il est capital les dérives
elles sont nombreuses à l'instar de ce
que nous avons pu évoquer pour le tabac
nous n'avons plus à rappeler les dangers
les impacts de la consommation de
l'alcool sur la société puis un coup
humain évidemment économique aussi c'est
une centaine de milliards d'euros par an
qui sont imputables à la consommation
d'alcool
vous le savez notre droit sur cette
question est axé sur fondée sur une loi
importante la loi E20 qui encadre
strictement la publicité de l'alcool sur
plusieurs supports en prévoyant un
principe d'interdiction générale et des
exceptions exception ce sont par exemple
les tranches horaires des radios
l'absence d'exception pour la télévision
la presse destinée à la jeunesse et le
parrainage est interdit lorsqu'il fait
la propagande de l'alcool
notre proposition comporte et vous
l'avez souligné une influencée notable
l'extension
l'inscription de la loi Evain pour les
influenceurs qu'il y ait des avantages
en nature ou un une rémunération
économique ce point est important
elle doit et elles devront toutes ces
publicités faire mention du message
sanitaire évidemment y compris lorsqu'il
s'agira d'un avantage en nature et c'est
pour cela que cette ajout était
importante l'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé en étant visible ne devra
pas être intrusive et nous donc pas
apparaître sur le fil des abonnés ne
revêtir aucun caractère positif tant sur
la position de l'influenceur que sur la
consommation d'alcool par exemple mise
en scène à la piscine avec un cocktail
mais il y en a bien d'autres aujourd'hui
finalement la plupart des publications
par des influenceurs
l'extrême majorité presque la totalité
rentre déjà dans le cadre de la loi E20
ce qu'il faut c'est l'affaire appliquer
et ça c'est un sujet qui relève de la
responsabilité du gouvernement notamment
et le Parlement ne peut qu'être
spectateur malheureusement à l'heure
actuelle de l'ampleur des de ce qui se
passe et je salue à ce titre addiction
France et vous l'avez fait également ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est donc de
jurisprudence et d'action mais c'est
pourquoi nous avons rappelé voilà à
l'article de Ace que j'ai dit mais parce
que nous souhaitons mettre fin à ces
dérives et par exemple il y a des
comptes YouTube spécialisés dans la
promotion d'alcool je citerai Coco Bongo
354000 abonnés il ne devrait pas exister
ses comptes il ne devrait pas exister et
j'en appelle solennellement aux
plateformes supprimer ces comptes car
sinon c'est la justice qui devra s'en
saisir
s'agissant
s'agissant de votre amendement nous
partageons naturellement l'objectif tout
comme l'amendement de Monsieur Bricout
182 et d'ailleurs la proposition de loi
telle qu'elle avait été adoptée par la
commission des affaires économiques
celle que j'avais moi-même présenté en
février dernier contenait le principe de
l'interdiction d'alcool par sur par les
influenceurs lors d'une publicité
commerciale
j'entends ce qui s'est passé en
commission et nous avons obtenu une un
accord sur l'insertion de la loi Évin
donc à titre personnel je ne peux
qu'être favorable à votre proposition
mais en tant que rapporteur je donnerai
un avis défavorable et je rajouterai à
l'intention du gouvernement mais aussi à
l'intention de l'ensemble des collègues
comme vous l'avez fait dans une
proposition de loi que vous avez déposée
j'appellerai solennellement le Parlement
à se saisir du cadre de la loi Eva parce
que comme vous le disiez la middelka a
appelé à renforcer et à retravailler sur
le cadre mais pas simplement sur
l'influence mais sur la question de la
promotion de l'alcool en ligne qui est
un véritable fléau merci madame la
Présidente je voulais revenir sur la loi
Eva avec le refus de cet amendement le
problème c'est que les influenceurs
seront les seuls autorisés à faire des
vidéos faisant promotion de l'alcool
parce qu'aujourd'hui la télévision et le
cinéma l'interdisent donc là on
introduit une différence d'égalité une
à l'égalité sur les différents supports
et vraiment je crois que c'est pas le
bon message à envoyer je voulais je
voulais spécifier mais les enjeux sont
trop importants au territoire dans le
territoire dans lequel je viens ces
trois quarts de violences qui sont sur
fond d'alcool on a un vrai problème
là-dessus nous devons envoyer un message
fort et vraiment vraiment la presse
écrite c'est pas la même chose que les
plateformes donc nous devons plutôt
rapprocher l'interdiction sur l'alcool
de ce que nous appliquons déjà à la
télévision et au cinéma parce que ça
s'en rapproche beaucoup plus je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
monsieur le rapporteur oui pour rebondir
sur les interventions simplement pour
aller dans le sens de mon collègue de la
porte moi je pense après avoir étudié en
profondeur le sujet que l'addition de la
loi Evin des règlements en vigueur de
l'Union européenne notamment
aboutissent à une interdiction de facto
pour les influenceurs une impossibilité
de facto pour les influenceurs de
continuer à faire le genre de publicité
qu'il faisait jusqu'à maintenant et on
pourra vous le démontrer mais il y a
notamment la directive 8952 de la
Communauté européenne de l'époque il n'a
rien de la Cour de cassation de 1995 qui
interdit la publicité et ça s'applique
aux influenceurs qui mettent en scène la
consommation d'alcool ou qui met en
scène d'alcool ou qui présente une
partie de personnalité en train de
consommer l'alcool sous un jour
favorable ou encore tout simplement qui
qui montre sous un jour favorable
défavorable l'abstinence ou la
modération à partir de là vraiment notre
texte il a une virtuelle éducative et je
vais m'adresser à la à la ministre en
demandant notamment à Bercy suite
l'aboutissement de ce texte de mettre à
jour le guide des bonnes pratiques
notamment pour refléter la manière dont
le texte aura évolué et notamment
peut-être de nourrir encore plus et
d'être encore plus explicite sur ce qui
implique la loi Évin pour aider vraiment
les influenceurs à comprendre l'étendue
des interdictions et des limitations qui
s'appliquent à eux dans le cadre strict
de l'application de la loi actuelle qui
d'après moi aboutit sur une interdiction
de facto
merci monsieur le rapporteur nous allons
maintenant procéder au scrutin je vais
donc mettre voilà l'amendement 47 qui a
reçu un double avis défavorable
commission et gouvernement je vous prie
de bien vouloir regagner vos places le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 63
exprimé 62 majorité 32 pour 28 contre 34
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
c'est des bases sur les interdictions
pose une question la législation qui
encadre la publicité doit-elle être
identique pour les médias et pour le
marketing d'influence au nom du principe
de cohérence certains députés repoussent
les amendements de la gauche pour
encadrer voire interdire la promotion de
la malbouffe des boissons trop sucrées
ou trop salées Dominique Pottier finit
quand même par arracher à une voix près
l'interdiction pour les influenceurs de
moins de 16 ans de faire la promotion de
ce type de produit regardez
je sens dans les avis qui sont donnés
par Madame la Ministre et les
rapporteurs une forme de mauvaise
conscience alors je vais essayer de vous
libérer
j'ai essayé de vous libérer avec avec
l'amendement 40 avec l'amendement 40 on
a on a deux horizons et moi je suis
heureux de l'engagement des deux
rapporteurs le premier c'est de
dupliquer la sélection mineure par et
majeur dans les plateformes à d'autres
champs que celui des jeux et là la
question de la santé publique est
ouverte et c'est une collaboration que
c'est là qu'il permet d'aller plus loin
je crois que nous partageons assez cette
piste il y a un horizon plus lointain
qui est de reprendre la régulation de la
publicité par rapport aux enjeux majeurs
et la bombe à retardement sanitaire
notamment liée à la malbouffe à la
sédentarité donc là il y a un autre
horizon mais à court terme on peut au
moins faire une chose pour ne pas se
quitter en fin d'après-midi avec avec
une mauvaise humeur c'est la question la
dernière l'amendement de repli que
propose des socialistes sur la malbouffe
c'est de dire que un enfant de moins de
16 ans
n'a pas à faire de pub auprès d'autres
enfants pour de la malbouffe des
boissons sucrées etc pourquoi je dis ça
parce que il y a une sorte de gradation
dans l'ignomini il y a des influenceurs
adultes qui vont instrumentaliser des
enfants mais je trouve qu'il est encore
pire que des adultes instrumentalisent
des enfants pour influencer d'autres
enfants et là il y a vraiment un
problème alors on peut parler de d'un
pas dans la porte pour la première fois
on pourrait dire que les mineurs non pas
de la porte ouais tout à fait on va
mettre un pas de la porte dire que les
mineurs n'ont pas été instrumentalisées
par des adultes pour influencer sur des
produits nocifs d'autres enfants ça je
pense que c'est une question à la fois
de protection des uns et des autres des
influenceurs mineurs et des victimes de
cette influence
merci monsieur le député à vie de la
commission oui je réalise que je dois
compléter mon avis antérieur qui n'avait
pas je n'ai pas bien lu l'article en
fait on parle effectivement de
d'influenceurs de moins de 16 ans qui
pourrait faire la promotion de ces
produits nous l'avons déjà eu de l'EVA
ce matin d'ailleurs sur un sujet
similaire et avons fait référence à la
gestuder qui est correctement intégrée
dans ce texte avec tous ces effets et
donc à partir de là nous souscrivons un
objectif général que vous portez
concernant la lutte contre l'obésité en
particulier chez les mineurs mais nous
souhaitons rester dans le cadre
protecteur de la Studer que nous avons
renforcé par ailleurs et donc pour le
même argumentaire que précédemment avis
défavorable
je voulais venir en soutien à mon
collègue le député potier sur cette
amendement en apportant peut-être un
témoignage j'ai 27 ans je fais partie de
cette génération qui est née avec les
réseaux sociaux qui a grandi avec des
réseaux sociaux qui se sont développés
en masse et qui ont été mal régulés peu
réguler et aujourd'hui on a une occasion
unique de se dire nous parlementaires et
ce que oui ou non on va plus loin ou
est-ce qu'on laisse passer la prochaine
occasion sur le sujet de la santé des
jeunes c'est un sujet essentiel on le
dit depuis ce matin vous voyez bien que
que le débat vient et revient et que
visiblement n'est pas tout à fait
satisfait sur ce sujet on entend
parfaitement l'argument sur la
concurrence que cela pose mais posez
aujourd'hui un cadre qui donne une
indication qui va permettre à nos
collègues sénateurs de travailler par la
suite ce texte c'est une c'est un c'est
un sujet important et on aimerait au
moins par l'un de ses amendements donner
un signe qui permettrait de porter le
débat dans l'autre chambre aujourd'hui
il faut quand même savoir que un enfant
sur 6 en surpoids le restera à adulte on
est en train de se poser la question
d'interdire pour une partie des réseaux
seulement les réseaux sociaux uniquement
les boissons qui sont sucrées et qui
sont nocives pour la santé c'est prouver
je pense qu'on pourrait tout à fait
apporter notre soutien à notre collègue
au moins de manière symbolique sur ce
plan là je vous remercie moi je retiens
deux choses par rapport aux arguments
madame la ministre je suis sûr de notre
sincérité à tous les deux dans ce débat
la première chose c'est que la loi
portait avec beaucoup d'intelligence par
Bruno Studer qui a été adopté je crois à
l'unanimité qui vise à protéger les
mineurs dans le cadre du mannequinat en
2020 était une bonne loi droit du
travail il me semble que dans le domaine
des influenceurs parce que nous sommes
dans le domaine familial dans le domaine
de la convivial dans des cadres privés
je ne suis pas sûr de son efficience du
tout et les risques de manipulation des
enfants qui eux-mêmes manipuleront notre
enfance sont avérés donc la loi Studer
appliquée aux influenceurs
personnellement je n'y crois pas et puis
de Louise Morel nous indique la voix
finalement nous avons une navette
parlementaire vous ne manquez pas d'a
pour les plus conservateurs elle est
libéraux d'entre vous au Sénat donc je
dis au moins à l'Assemblée nationale
posons la question de la minorité dans
l'influence comme un sujet qui pourra
être traité ultérieurement au Sénat et
dans le cadre d'une CMP mais ayons de
l'ont peut-être une indication cet
après-midi d'une perspective qui
trouvera son accomplissement dans cette
loi dans des lois futures mais on le
courage de poser la question de la
minorité de l'influence que le règlement
encore une fois la loi de pronostics une
observation et c'est un peu un pavé dans
la marre là on est en train de
phosphorer sur la question des
influenceurs qui même si le chiffre
d'affaires est important reste marginal
par rapport aux canaux je dirais
traditionnel de la publicité mais à
partir du moment où on s'attaque à ces
produits qui font du mal à nos enfants
via les influenceurs il va peut-être
falloir qu'on s'occupe également des
publicitaires qui ont pignon sur rue je
suis désolé mais les mineurs passent
beaucoup de temps devant la télévision
également nous avons des spots télévisés
qui font la promotion de ces produits
sucrés de ces produits gras et on voit
le chiffre le biais ité infantile monté
en flèche année après année donc la
question devra se poser mais n'oublions
pas que derrière il y a des enjeux
financiers importants et des milliers
d'emplois la clé donc je vais mettre on
voit cet amendement numéro 40 qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission et
du gouvernement et qui fait l'objet d'un
scrutin public le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 73 exprimé 73 majorité 37 pour 37
contre 36 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
et pour les influenceurs qui ne
respecteraient pas les interdictions
publicitaires elle est députée vote des
sanctions jusqu'à 300000 € d'amende et 6
mois de prison vous l'avez compris ce
travail transpartisan a permis des
débats apaisés une cinquantaine
d'amendements viennent d'ailleurs
enrichir la proposition de loi en fin de
journée le jeudi 30 mars les députés se
prononcent sur l'ensemble du texte
alors je n'ai pas reçu de demande
d'explication de vote sur ce texte donc
je vais mettre au voie l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi qui fait l'objet d'un
scrutin public que j'ai annoncé tout à
l'heure dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
[Musique]
votant 49 exprimer 49 majorités 25 pour
49 contre 0
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
oui merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues je vais faire très brièvement
des remerciements à l'ensemble des
responsables des groupes avec qui nous
avons travaillé vraiment avec mon
collègue Stéphane vogeta dans un esprit
de Concorde qui fait du bien dans un
esprit d'apaisement et surtout dans un
esprit de construction positive de la
loi dans un souci d'intérêt général et
partagé laissez-moi également remercier
nos collaborateurs sans qui rien de tout
ceci n'aurait été possible
je pense à Gautier la garde de
collaborateur de Stéphane Neopole
Benatar mon collaborateur et aussi les
administrateurs précieux de la
commission des affaires économiques
Benjamin nourdi et Estelle en stage qui
nous ont accompagnés pendant ces deux
mois finalement parce qu'il faut le
reconnaître nous avons eu deux mois de
rapporteur quasiment puisque j'ai été
désigné rapporteur pour la commission de
février donc nous avons travaillé avec
Benjamin depuis mi-janvier finalement ce
qui est assez rare et ce qui est gage de
qualité donc n'hésitez pas à désigner
plutôt les rapporteurs et à mettre
encore plus d'administrateurs à leur
côté pour que le Parlement se saisisse
enfin de son pouvoir
confirmer les les paroles de
remerciement de mon cher cooporteur je
ne sais pas si tu disais mentionné mais
merci beaucoup à Violette spielbout et à
Dominique Pottier nos responsables des
textes pour leur contribution et leur
capacité à nous amener à bon port sur
finalement un résultat qui je pense
satisfaisant pour l'ensemble des groupes
sur ses bancs et je pense que le c'est
assez rare pour le souligner un vote à
l'unanimité je pense que pour nous c'est
ces missions accomplies on aura réussi à
faire une première un texte qui pour la
première fois en Europe permet
d'encadrer un secteur important et qui
va qui est appelé à l'être de plus en
plus donc merci à tous pour votre
soutien et bonne chance au Sénat dans la
prochaine étape de l'examen de ce texte
merci messieurs les rapporteurs
prochaine séance lundi 3 avril à 16h
avec le débat sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme d'extrême droite puis le
débat sur le thème l'école inclusive une
réalité avant de suspendre je donne la
parole à Monsieur le Ministre j'en ai
pas vu qu'il l'avait demandé
les mots qu'il fallait bien évidemment
je voulais au nom du gouvernement vous
aussi vous remercier pour la qualité du
travail réalisé Bruno Le Maire Lille et
Grégoire vous le savez suivant ont suivi
entre travailler avec vous pour la
préparation de cette proposition là moi
je voudrais aussi remercier les deux
rapporteurs
remercier les différents orateurs des
textes remercier bien évidemment tous
les services de l'Assemblée mais aussi
du gouvernement pour la qualité des
débats le président de la commission
qu'on ne doit pas oublier et vous dire
que quand en tant que ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement au-delà de
la qualité du texte qui est important
non seulement pour nos compatriotes mais
aussi pour les influenceurs eux-mêmes
c'est vous dire que de voir la qualité
du travail de l'Assemblée nationale
l'image que ça a donné j'en suis ravi et
quand je suis arrivé pour vous faire une
confidence tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée
pour remplacer Olivia Grégoire judo je
suis tombé sur Dominique potier qui m'a
dit oh là là c'est formidable on a fait
un travail extraordinaire ça fait du
bien et donc un député heureux et des
députés heureux c'est aussi quelque
chose qui compte pour le ministre en
charge des relations avec le Parlement
donc bra VO à tous
merci Monsieur le Ministre la séance est
levée
un texte voté à l'unanimité après son
passage au Sénat la proposition de loi a
fait l'objet d'un accord entre députés
et sénateurs en commission mixte
paritaire un accord qui ajoute notamment
d'autres interdictions pour certaines
publicités et qui durcit les sanctions
avec des peines de prison pouvant aller
jusqu'à 2 ans le Parlement adopte
définitivement la proposition de loi le
premier juin ce qui fait de la France
l'un des premiers pays au monde à
réguler le secteur des influenceurs
merci de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
sur LCP
[Musique]